valérie bénaïm vanter pmp c'est un peu
la première de la classe qui a toujours
réponse à tout mesdames vous ai fait
quoi ce week-end je suis allé voir
l'exposition vasarely à pompe à beinheim
elle a fait un jour un musée sereno
tayssir interesser demander si
république je suis une othello mais
derrière ce masque d'élèves surdoué se
cache une ado rebelle il n'a pas peur de
remettre à sa place le prof principal
est tu sais quoi quoi redescendant si
valérie et première en classe elle est
aussi premier à la cantine surtout quand
au menu du séjour de boulettes
on va cueillir maintenant miss meurthe
et boulettes les faits
benaïssa ring pas et coquine un ca
remake tajine
valérie bénaïm une élève à mi chemin
entre l'égérie fabio salsa et edwy
plenel grâce à une coupe et une
moustache toujours impeccable je pars au
parc astérix à lorient vous abonnez vous
mais c'est aussi une élève qui a fait
anglais élevé 1
du coup elle est capable de faire
connaissance avec ses correspondants
étrangers interview à la récré pour
valérie c'est que leur image de coeur à
la craie avec un seul et unique prénom
dessinée à l'intérieur celui de patoche
bien sûr nous regarde d'ailleurs elle
rentrera aux alentours de 21h30 alors à
vous d'attribuer notamment neri et
surtout n'oubliez pas vous êtes le 5 et
volutes surtout si vous voulez la voir
revenir l'année prochaine ou pas les
chéris aller castaldi allez vous allez
tu sais à quel point je t'aime j'ai un
vrai problème avec toi j'ai toujours
détesté les premiers de la classe ça va
toujours gonfler ceux qui sont toujours
un vague des fils bienfaits qu'ils ont
toujours 32 fitch qui tirait pas de
grands débats lavail et ceux qui bossent
simple ça me gonfle erwitt est parfait
tu parle anglais tu parle espagnol
tu connais tout sur tout voilà et bien
j'en ai marre d'eux bénin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
suite ces 28 et là il y va fort j'avais
réussi à la pécho donc voilà que de la
frustration aller aurait demandé à son
ami parce que mine de rien c'est votre
ami gérald humaniste dont on est le plus
légitime et celle que vous connaissiez
avant même tout le monde vous la
connaissiez maman vont mois 15 novembre
oui moi ces montants là pas de date
précise alors valérie ccima meilleur ami
tu le sais tu es un peu la soeur ça
n'est jamais la meilleure amie temps et
là on est ma meilleure année soit
unanime ta meilleure amie absolument pas
avec des amis comme ça on n'a pas besoin
d'ennemis
j'estime que j'ai beaucoup de chance
cyril [ __ ] mais limitée réciproque
c'est ma meilleure amie non à nanning
c'est pourquoi elle me démontre mais
bien sûr que non c'est pas vrai donc en
fait moi je pense que cette année c'est
un meilleur en et entend chronique où tu
t'es rebeller tu as cassé l'armure et
pour moi tu es la béquille de cyril à la
barbie ouais hein
le thé sont à quai en fête tesson alpha
et son int et son rayon de soleil
si tu n'es pas là il flanche pour madrid
la pépite féminines ii s'est vite un
problème il faut que tu te salissent un
peu plus de ces fines il est mon style
bonhomme il faut un fuck you grow tarbes
a un truc comme ça un peu prévu pour ça
je te mets en off d'accord
entendu il m'a dit qu'il fallait que je
vous dise tokyo grootaers ben oui
ballack aldi avec banderas est
apparemment de se débarrasser alors
venez rire vérité un peu là nagui de ces
huttes entre trouve à toutes les sauces
et c'est pas toi que je vais apprendre
qu'une boulette contre la troupe dans
plusieurs choses on peut difficilement
avaler mais y'a un truc un don pour
faire une belle boulette il faut la
faire avec amour et tu n'est qu'amour ma
note c'est tout mais inspiré cinq cas
n'oubliez tablettes les séquelles
chroniqueur c'est la même eau et en
régime est isolé il nous a manqué quand
même gagné c'est plutôt 10 en régie non
non c'est faux assurent de leur bus
selon lui beynat tu me rappelle un petit
peu moins soutenu dans cette émission
merde t'es un pilier après j'ai pas
parlé de tabac ou à appuyer moi j'aime
est venu qu'un pilier quoi tu m'a jamais
vu nu les limites on vous voit tout nous
peut faire une toupie jagger c'est moi
un jour tu me provoque bons gènes comme
ça les a tenus montrer ici ouais bien
sûr important une bagarre kanouté c'est
bondé 1000 cadeaux j'en ai vu clair
après ménagez pas dire tes qualités
parce qu'on s'en fout c'est pas drôle on
va aller sur les ddt comme ta coiffure
tétreault disent avoir un avis comme les
et patrick bruel ceux qui aiment tout le
monde n'aime personne ou bien tout le
monde
mais bah oui je cite des auteurs pardon
pas une armée au claf audriel un petit
moment il faut il faut oser dire tout
d'un coup bas tel animateur chez packard
est ce par respect des tailles comptage
par nagui les muscles temps je m'habille
n'a après il ya un petit poème de melon
comme tu as fait beaucoup de cartons
cette année beaucoup d'émissions tu
commences à te prendre pour une
animatrice attention et n'oublie jamais
kanak de sur cette chaîne avant
cyril moi et moi animatrice et après on
parlait des compresses d'eau et des
matériaux
surtout toi après on parlait des
contrefaçons animateur il ya castaldi en
prime time y en a d'autres mais c'est
vrai que s'il aimerait d'ailleurs quand
avec cyril on réfléchit au tour de table
et qu'on me demande qui va être là la
semaine on pense souvent à toi m'at on
dit attention que bénin muscle son jeu
qu'elle soit comme ci ou comme ça fait
juste tennis et après pour le reste je
termine série n'aime pas qu'on le dise
mais je le dis quand même oui tu est
indispensable dans cette émission tu es
sympathique tué généreuse quand tu ris
c'est pour de vrai tu fais partie des
rares animateurs ou tristes j'en connais
peut-être que quatre ou cinq dans ce
milieu qui sont vraiment vraiment des
gens bien en dehors de la caméra et dieu
sait si ce milieu est fait de connard et
j'en sais quelque chose je te mets à 9
mon coeur
[Applaudissements]
très bonne camarade qui est devenue une
amie mais me lèche cul me rebelle à ça
ça me plait pas va falloir que je trouve
ton camp alors j'étais bien 4c ou tuent
des gens elles tuent les griffes a eu
vraiment très vite très vite alors très
vite ça va être dur moi variées alors
quand effet destination d'abord pour ses
que de la télé parce que ça cartonne et
souvent sans voix et textos vraie
citation
moi j'aime bien la manière que tu as de
me recadrer parfois quand je dis des
conneries c'est toujours bienveillant en
dehors tu me dis toujours les mots qui
qui qui calme bien donc ça bravo pour la
saison parfait jeu que je partage l'avis
de géraldine as tu fait une très bonne
saison le pilier de cyril oui c'est
comme tous les duos tu avais de caunes
les gars y attendent un moment donné qu
il avait cécile avec avec lui tu as tu
un tarif tout je pense que tu fais
partie du duo légende a fait 6e et les
bus comme comparer à fred et jamy
réservé mais les jours il faut toujours
cac est une femme qui soit là avec
l'expérience qu'a fait de la télé et je
vais finir vite fait j'adore ces gens
qui ont eu un début de carrière fort à
tf1 et tous et qu'après on une petite
traversée du désert ah oui ça les roues
mais bien des pierres c'était après
quand il renouvelle à une le succès
quand il rompre reprendre le super bien
leur gueule c'est donc pour ça je mets
8,5
il reste mamie on est sur ma mine où tu
décides de ma mois bébé oui mais
maitient moi non mais non ça ta mère est
derrière alors et le sait je viens de
comprendre que j'étais loin de sa
meilleure amie et pourtant j'ai emmené
qu'elle-même mademoiselle valérie tant
pis ça va me faciliter la suite parce
que valérie elle se fait dans des
groupes par l'émission prend 30 m'en
fous c'est comme une voiture affliction
vous l'affrontez bombe après sa part
tout seul
et donc elle se chauffe danser que de la
télé elle se chauffe et quand elle
arriva touche pas à mon poste elle est
au taquet et elle continue sur sa lancée
ce qui fait qu'elle ouvre beaucoup
surtout et que du coup comment on a
souvent le même ma vie j'ai strictement
plus rien à dire après avant sa mort
mieux le salaire vous avez
aller avant de finir par jean michel
lemaire e et g c'est court ouais merci
merci oui tu es sûr là aussi web on va
voir ça commence par la note ou non
regarder un petit peu tes camarades
aussi oublié alors ah oui alors je
commence par la note b temia laurent
castaing sur 19
mes frères tu crois qu'ils te disent
qu'à 110 le montana mais perd mais tu te
fous de ma gueule mais moi une note sur
10 modèles de merde alors dit déjà ce
que tu penses de 1 m à 1 sur 10 heures
merci valérie offert un cadeau souhaite
bonne santé la joie de mariée de vivre
jusqu'à 120 ans elle affiche de mamie ça
peut faire des belles émissions
diffusées dans le monde entier des
enfants sains et que des bonnes choses
ces enfants
mais la note
ce qu'on veut on peut alors 10 sur
combien dix sur dix dans l'instant ce
qu'ils pensent de valérie benaïm ce
qu'ils pensent vraiment le ballet des
médailles mais je peux vous dire ça va
chier les bus car oui jean michel oui
moi je veux pas être très objectif donc
je vais essayer de faire court ce que me
valérie depuis le temps qu'on la
côtoient c'est notre mama à tous même si
le casa blanca murray accepte ce terme
de ma match est pas qu on cesse d'être
le cas voilà non tu n'es pas trop gentil
tu es bienveillante
non tu n'es pas influençable tu n'es pas
buté non tu n'es pas des ouïes béni oui
oui tu as ton caractère est même un sale
petit caractère quand on t'emmerde
et voilà et ça c'est de plus en plus et
ça c'est bien non tu n'es pas
descriptions contenues et pudique avoir
tué la plus dans le carré avec badge la
main sur ce plateau
en revanche oui tu es leur nourriture et
drôle oui tu intelligente et oui je
t'aime
[Musique]
les slips
je suis hyper ému non seulement vous
avez senti vous cette année parce que
c'est vrai que cette année on t'a vu à
toutes les sauces pâtes et ptt la
harissa de ses 8 elle était partout
lottin lolo barenton laurent elle va
dire
[Applaudissements]
ces gens là ce qui mise en scène écrit
par laurent baffie
ce sera le 17 juin bien sûr on va aller
voir richard d'ailleurs richard
deviendrait devoir c'est sûr et certain
mon chéri merci le voir très peu de
spectacle c'est vrai c'est le procès de
valérie oui alors valérie benaïm
commentaire comment tu as senti ton âne
il est lourd on dire aussi ce qu'ils
pensent de toi dans la ville hôte des jo
et bat pour tous les riches crois que
c'est ma plus belle année
non mais on a plus belle allée chez sony
c'est à dire je suis au delà de heureuse
non c'est vrai parce que je suis entouré
de gens que j'aime infiniment qui sont
extrêmement bienveillant ou sachets sont
des vrais noms autour de la table c'est
des vrais camarades je les vois plus que
ma propre famille et je les aime
vraiment pour de vrai ouais ils me
disent les choses réellement quand on se
parle et ils me disent 'voilà est
vraiment tu m'as bien fait ça et même
toi je t'aime
alors moi je peux te dire mais bon mais
je t'aime et voilà est donc vraiment jeu
qu'est ce que tu veux dire quand tu
travailles dans une ambiance comme ça
avec des gens que tu aimes réel et du
mal de quelqu'un quand même non je n'ai
pas envie parce que vraiment pour deux
pour le coup je suis très ému parce que
vous êtes vraiment des mes amis
7 62 14 dessureault disent les
chroniqueurs auto 1695
s'il te fenua une générale de
saint-hubert eu l'occasion dix ans et
alors sur le sondage de ce que vous a
envie de la voir sa gueule l'année
prochaine
pour ce faire on va le voir suite la à
l'or et aux eaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]